vamos a resolver el siguiente ejercicio
nos piden considerar la gráfica de la
función f x y realmente no nos dicen
quién es la función simplemente nos dan
el dibujo de su gráfica ok y nos dice
que tiene segmentos secantes como se
muestra en la figura y hay que completar
la siguiente tabla entonces déjenme
bajar un poco para que veas realmente el
problema aquí está la gráfica aquí están
los puntos que nos dan y estas líneas
punteadas son las líneas secantes que
conectan a estos tres puntos muy bien
esta línea azul otra vez es la gráfica
de la función f x y nos piden rellenar
con igual menor o mayor bueno hay que
comparar el lado izquierdo con el lado
derecho por ejemplo el primero nos dice
si h es menor mayor o igual que 1 muy
bien y entonces hay que comparar varias
de estas cosas así que vamos a hacerlo
mejor en la herramienta de dibujo
aquí tenemos exactamente
la gráfica y hay que rellenar aquí
entonces lo primero que voy a hacer es
lo siguiente vamos a comparar h con 1
muy bien entonces vamos a comparar h con
1 y esencialmente quien es h si nos dan
todo esto si nos damos cuenta aquí
estamos
justamente en el punto 2 y cuando nos
movemos hacia la izquierda o hacia la
derecha h unidades ok
estamos en este otro punto este de aquí
este de aquí sería 2 - h entonces de
aquí es inmediato ver también lo podemos
ver de este lado verdad que por acá anda
2 + h 2 + h si nos damos cuenta al
restarle h no llegamos a 1 entonces
quiere decir que le quitamos a 2 mucho
bueno le quitamos a 2 menos que 1 verdad
es decir está h tiene que ser menor que
1 entonces vamos a escribirlo aquí menor
que 1 verdad no alcanzamos ni siquiera a
quitarle uno para poder llegar a éste
entonces este estuvo muy sencillo ahora
lo que nos piden es comparar efe de 2 +
h vamos a comparar
efe 2 + h - efe de 2 / h con respecto a
efe de 2
efe de 2 exacto menos efe 2 - h / h
entonces si nos damos cuenta esto tiene
cara como de fórmula de una pendiente de
una recta verdad y lo es y lo es
esencialmente lo que nos dicen es tomate
este es el cambio y este sería nuestro
camión y ya abajo nuestro cambio en x
entonces el cambio en yes
efe 2 + h - efe de 2 esencialmente nos
están diciendo es que voy a hacerlo con
un color más fuerte porque ese casi no
se ve nos están diciendo es este cambio
verdad estamos hasta aquí
este cambio de aquí esto es nuestro
cambio y ahora nos dicen que el cambio
en x es h que justamente coincide con
esto entonces lo que nos piden es
calcular la pendiente de esta recta
secante y con respecto a de esta
pendiente que es efe 2 - efe 2 - h vamos
a hacerlo con azul
efe 2 - efe 2 - h aquí está efe 2 - h
efe 2 - h y aquí está
efe de 2 muy bien entonces nos piden
calcular este cambio este cambio de aquí
y dividir entre el cambio en x que es h
que es justamente esto entonces nos
piden comparar esta línea books
déjeme ver si puedo
hacerlo bien esta de aquí con respecto a
esta de acá
entonces qué es lo que podemos fijarnos
nada más de ver el dibujo yo sé que es
un poco complicado verlo por sobre todo
por cómo está pintada la gráfica pero
esta línea de aquí está out déjenme
pintarlo con azul esta línea de aquí si
lo extrapolamos se ve más o menos así
y más o menos y esta rosa la podemos ver
entonces por cómo se cruzan justamente
podemos ver que la rosa es más es menos
pronunciada que el azul verdad la azul
la atraviesa entonces es más pronunciada
quiere decir que esto de aquí si
comparamos estas dos cosas la primera
que dibujamos fue la rosa y la segunda
que dibujamos fue el azul esta es más
chica que esta es la pendiente verdad
entonces vamos a ponerlo como menor aquí
hasta que la rosa es más chica ahora nos
dicen comparar
efe de dos más h voy a hacerlo digamos
con verde efe de 2 + h - efe 2 - h sobre
h que otra vez tienes esto obtenemos efe
de dos más h vamos a ponerlo aquí esto
es f de 2 + h y hay que restarle efe 2 -
h entonces lo que estamos calculando es
esta altura esta altura muy bien y si
dividimos entre y aquí de hecho divide
entre 2 h no entre h
entonces cuanto es 2 h pues justo es
aquí va una h hasta aquí y luego no
seguimos y va a 2h entonces lo que nos
pide es ahora comparar la pendiente de
esta línea verde que es la línea secante
con respecto a efe de dos más h - efe de
2 entre h
esa es la pendiente de la recta rosa
entonces la rosa hace
verdad y la verde por
hace algo así quiere decir otra vez que
la verde es más pronunciada que la rosa
entonces aquí debe ir un mayor que muy
bien y finalmente nos piden comparar
estas dos cosas y eso lo voy a hacer
fácilmente con simplemente haciendo
cálculos fíjense tenemos efe de 2 + h
- efe de 2 / h y hay que sumarle efe 2 -
efe 2 - h sobre h muy bien y esto
dividirlo entre 2 entonces esto es
simplemente 2 bueno vamos a tener un 2
en el denominador y podemos sacar un
denominador común que es h y tener
efe de 2 + h - efe de 2 y aquí viene lo
bueno porque hay que sumar efe 2 - efe 2
- h muy bien entonces tenemos esto estos
se cancelan y simplemente tendremos efe
de 2 + h
2 efe 2 - h / y aquí está h la podemos
pasar abajo 2 h entonces resulta que
esta expresión de la izquierda fue igual
a la de la derecha esto será igual y
ahora ya tenemos esto resuelto
simplemente vamos a ponerlo en la página
de lacan academy para que veamos que si
son la respuesta correcta solo hay que
acordarnos menor menor mayor igual menor
menor mayor igual entonces va a ser
menor menor mayor igual y vamos a
comprobar y estamos correctos